من الخليج العربي شرقا وحتى المحيط
الاطلسي غربا كانت جامعه الدول العربيه
لنحو ثمانيه عقود حاضره ومظله للدول
العربيه وشعوبها في الازمات فعلى طاولتها
ناقش العرب اصعب قضاياهم الشائكه
تاريخيا يعود تاسيس جامعه الدول العربيه
الى مارس من العام
1945 لتكون بذلك الاقدم بين المنظمات
العربيه والاقليميه والدوليه منذ نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
فقبيل التاسيس كان العالم يعيش مرحله
حساسه انعكست بطبيعه الحال على المنطقه
فمن ناحيه كانت بوادر نهايه الحرب فرصه
مواتيه لتكاتف الجهود ما اسهم في استقلال
عدد من الدول العربيه ومن ناحيه اخرى
تعززت الحاجه الى الوحده في ظل بروز مخاطر
اقليميه وما صاحب هذه المرحله من احتكاك
متزايد بالغرب ومعاصره تطور النظام الدولي
كلها كانت عوامل محفزه لظهور الجامعه
العربيه التي ولدت فعليا بتوقيع بروتوكول
الاسكندريه عام
1944 حيث كان اساس ميثاق جامعه الدول
العربيه لاحقا والذي وقعته سبع دول هي مصر
وسوريا والسعوديه وشرق الاردن ولبنان
والعراق واليمن ومن الدول السبع اتسعت
الرقعه الجغرافيه لعضويه الجامعه العربيه
لتشمل حتى الان 22 دوله جمعتها طاولتها
المستديره في الظروف العاديه والطارئه
باهداف مشتركه تصب لتحقيق المصالح وتوحيد
الصف تجاه مسرح الاحداث اقليميا ودوليا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات